so it's the morning of day three of the
trip I spent much of yesterday in the
special collection taking a break at
lunch just to go get hamburger at the
cafe got quite a bit of work done
yesterday although it's still you know
laying the groundwork for the database
that I am going to be putting together I
had some time to do a bit of reading in
the dissertations to look at some of the
interesting parts that actually fit in
with my own projects and I finished
putting together the spreadsheet that
everything is going to have to go into a
lot of work ahead and I've got to get
out of here pretty soon they're putting
in new windows in this dorm so the
maintenance guy just came in a minute
ago having my breakfast when I get a
shower change stole my gear and start
heading on up so today I'm having lunch
with with kevin mcmahon so we'll talk
about some some institute related things
I'm sure at launch and I've got starting
if the interviews wind up I've got
Montee locked in on Monday send emails
to father John fortin and Kevin Staley
I'm going to talk to kevin about doing
an interview always a little bit
reluctant at this point since he you
know sees himself as as you know just
sort of taking over what other people
have been doing and even though he's
actually doing important work with the
physics colloquium there's a lot of you
know genuine humility among among these
and some people not surprising since
that's very important for insomnia for
the Benedictines in general so my
typical breakfast here is stuff that the
main easily done gave off a lot of
cleanup once the hannaford the other day
and bought a bunch of muffins let's hold
me over as well till lunchtime hopefully
I've got my pineapple juice my coffee so
i'm going to do a little bit of reading
and then like I said a shower change get
out up to the Institute I've got plenty
of work to do up there I'm going to
decide what works I'm taking with me did
a little bit of filming yesterday as
well but filming for eventually creating
a series of gana song videos much like
the half hour Hagel videos on the pro
slow Jim took a lot of time to read it
turned out to be about an hour's worth
of footage you'd be surprised how many
takes I have to do because I'm you know
tripping over what I'm saying and as I'm
going through it and then of course your
mouth gets dried you start to cough or
things like that but that's done so
that's going to enable me to create some
more videos once i get back to to my
home base in Kingston New York so now
I'm going to have my breakfast do a bit
of ants on related reading and get out
of the day
it's mid-morning getting close to
lunchtime on day three and I have been
going through these dissertations
managed to discover that that one
database ProQuest dissertation abstracts
should have abstracts and perhaps
subject headings for most of them from
1980 on but that only covers a limited
amount and when we went into the
WorldCat which is a major database that
sort of think of it as sort of sucking
information on all its member libraries
when of the WorldCat there's there's
really no information for most of these
so what I'm going to have to do is
determine which of these dissertations I
want to spend the time on to try to do
both writing an abstract and keywords
I'm going to have to give priority I
think to those that actually have to do
with an some and not just with medieval
thought or medieval culture in general
but even that is quite a few there are
probably database something like well we
go up to about 1984 there are at least
25 to 30 dissertations that date from
from that period and i'm not sure that
they'll actually have abstracts in
ProQuest for the ones from 1980 when
they first started getting the
information to 1984 when I'm guessing
they probably started making sure that
they were actually collecting that that
information but I've got a clear idea
now about the work ahead I have the
remainder of today although I've got to
spend some of that time on my own
research projects and on some filming
got turns out a bit of Saturday where I
can work in here because I can't take
these dissertations out so I have to do
all the work while I'm actually in this
room and then I've got Monday and
Tuesday two full days although i will be
doing some filming and doing some of the
interviews during that time and then
Wednesday I've got the morning but
starting in the afternoon it's the meta
physics colloquium and so I'm going to
be tied up with that so really I would
say there's about three solid days of
work that I've got the chance to do with
these and then I've got to put into my
report as I'm building it for the
archivist all this information that I'm
coming across or generating so that's
what's going on day three I've also
spent a bit of time going through the
library materials that you can see up
there getting myself some books on an
some off of these shelves that then I
fit in with my particular research
projects that I'm working on right now
I'm an some prayer courteous homo and I
also went and grabbed a bunch of
Gabrielle Marcel works because I'm also
trying to work on this this article on
marcela and the Christian philosophy
debates so a lot of stuff to do don't
have that much time to take apart for
the filming but I thought I should sort
of check in and and talk about where
things are so far
it's the afternoon of day 3 and I am now
about to do some reading Hagel which
sounds a little strange for an Ansel
related research trip but actually what
I'm going to do is go through
self-consciousness the truth of self
certainty and the lordship and bondage
section and in part because i like the
backdrop and for the half hour Hagel
videos that i do its nicely on a sort of
continuity rather than just my my
bookshelves behind me so that's what I'm
going to do I just had a great launch
with kevin mcmahon lasted a little bit
more than i thought it was going to
which is cutting a little bit into the
work and research time but it's always
great to spend some time talking with
with colleagues some you know with peers
about things that I'm interested in and
things that he's interested in as well
he's a guy who does work in systematic
theology and moral theology we talked
about our-our dissertations way back
when the state of moral theology natural
law all sorts of really interesting
topics I got to pick his brain a little
bit for discussion a little bit of tree
schmutz there well I got to pick his
brain a little bit for discussion about
the relationship between mercy and
justice in thinkers prior to an some so
that was useful for me as well and I'm
going to be interviewing him later on in
this trip probably on Monday in this
this same area probably not in front of
these books but so that's what what's
been going on I also managed this
morning to get a lot of groundwork done
as far as finding out where I might be
able to get abstracts for quite a few of
these dissertations went through some of
them to find whether they had an
abstract in them you know did some more
work with the spreadsheet figured out
how I can code it so that Keith
chevalier de the librarian will be able
to
archivist will be able to see exactly
what I want conveyed in a very easy form
so that's what the morning was was spent
done now I've got about two and a half
hours left to go so we'll see how
quickly I can get through the Hagel and
then after I do that I'm probably going
to do some reading of these
dissertations prior to writing abstracts
for them
so it's about eight thirty at night now
and I am still at order rather back at
work I took a break a little bit after I
got back here around five o'clock I
checked email and took care of that sort
of stuff had something to eat went out
to the store got some more food and
supplies including some guinness because
it's a friday night and i'm still
working so i'm going to enjoy myself a
little bit and took a nap somewhere in
there for maybe half an hour or so so I
was feeling kind of run-down not
sleeping as well as I'd like that's a
factor of getting old used to be when I
was young I could sleep anywhere you
know even on top of an armored personnel
carrier when I was in in the army but as
you can hold your body tennis to crave
you know some of the same stuff that
you're used to so whenever I'm not
sleeping in my own bed it's a little bit
tougher and I wouldn't sleep in in the
morning but I need to get to the library
that decent time and to take advantage
of their hours so looking forward to
sleeping in a little bit tomorrow
although I need to get to the library by
10 because they're opening for alumni
day so in any case productive day I got
a lot of stuff done I got some Hagel
recorded that I talked about it in one
of the previous clips so that's good i
can use that footage for first part of
self-consciousness when i get to that
still have to get through force in the
understanding before i get to the
master-slave dialectic and i did
actually find that I could I could not
necessarily download but at least fine
pointers towards a lot of the abstracts
within the dissertations of quite a few
of the newer dissertations and even a
few of the older dissertations so that
is work that I think can be farmed out
productively to
the geisel library staff rather than
mini concentrating on it so now with my
spreadsheet I've got it set so i can see
exactly what I'm looking at and there's
some dissertations are not an some
related i'm not going to bother with
those you know I wouldn't be as
qualified to do stuff with them anyway
it you know frankly they don't get
priority and then there are quite a few
where there's already an abstract I
don't have to mess around with that it's
just not an abstract in the library
entry for the the piece and then there
is a good you know 15 or so that I think
I might be able to get to over the next
you know three days and produce some
abstracts for so that will be a
considerable help that will take me up
through the early 80s I think maybe even
the mid 80s that means that people that
come to the archive them to do research
will be able to access that that
abstract and know whether they want to
get that work off the shelf or not they
won't be like me who goes in and just
takes all the the works off of the shelf
and that goes through the one at a time
i can say to people time so you know
that that's a really important factor so
tonight I get to work on some of my own
projects and what I'm going to be doing
is polishing out the paper that I wrote
some time ago and presented about
niversity and justice and the courteous
homo and I need to insert some more
footnotes add a few more or
to rewrite a few sections to make it
sound a little bit better as it reads
and maybe some of that work will get
done with tomorrow as well but I'm
looking forward to actually not blocking
out a good probably three hours before I
knock off just to take care of this this
you know polishing up the long overdue
paper and then tomorrow I can start
working directly on the paper on Anselm
and prayer and mercy and justice and
that as well as the Marcel peace the
Aquinas peace and the epicurean
tradition stuff that I need to work on
as well because i'm going to put in a
short day at the library with the
dissertations so that's it for the day
I'll check in some more probably shoot
some in the morning for day 4 and put
that together with day 5 maybe I'll put
it together with the whole weekend so
you know I'm not clogging up the
internet with too many entries but I
wanted you to be able to see what with
the life of scholarship is let me
actually is going to show you this
before this is what scholarship looks
like quite often
you do a lot of reading so that's it
you